squids are shrinking birds are migrating
lizards are getting blown away by
hurricanes the signs are everywhere
animals are changing because of climate
change but few people expected it to
happen so fast we asked biologist tor
hansen to walk us through three animal
adaptation experiments
we know that climate change is making
hurricanes stronger in one of the best
examples comes to us from the turks and
caicos islands in the caribbean where a
small anole lizard a distant relative of
the iguana is facing increasing
challenges due to hurricanes
[Music]
it's a female
i know the scriptus on pine key soon
after field biologist colin donahue went
to the turks and caicos in 2017 to study
and take measurements of the lizards
back-to-back hurricanes irma and maria
devastated the islands
creating the perfect laboratory for him
to study natural selection in response
to climate change in real time it wasn't
just one hurricane it was two strong
hurricanes had any lizards survived
those hurricanes and if so was the
post-hurricane population different from
the one he had just measured when he
re-measured all those lizards out in the
wild he found that the survivors of the
hurricanes were different they all had
larger toe pads and they also had
shorter back legs when compared to the
population he'd measured beforehand so
the lizards that had small toe pads and
large long back legs perished during
that wind event so to prove that the
lizards with the shorter back legs and
larger toe pads were more fit to survive
during a hurricane donohue tested how
lizards reacted to winds by aiming his
leaf blower at them
he needed to see how the lizards behaved
during hurricane force winds and since
you can't be out there taking notes on
lizards during a real hurricane he
decided to recreate one with the leaf
blower on the porch of his hotel room he
put a dowel that was similar to the size
of the sticks that a lizard would hold
onto in the wild so there's the lizard
placed upon the dowel with the leaf
blower on hurricane force winds
legs slipping free flying in the wind as
the wind speed increased you can see the
lizard's back legs flying free and its
whole body flying like a flag in the
wind and it's gone
and i should say that no lizards were
harmed in the experiment itself he had a
soft net that caught all the lizards and
they were also returned to the wild
safely later then he understood that
when the lizard is flapping like a flag
in the wind shorter back legs reduce the
drag and it can hold on for a few
seconds longer and that might be the
difference between survival or death
what colin realized was that he had
measured evolution in action survival of
the fittest natural selection playing
out not over thousands of years but in
the course of a single field season and
then he looked at the same question from
a wider viewpoint across the whole
caribbean wherever strong hurricanes are
more frequent we see the same features
in the anole lizards the bigger toe pads
the stronger front legs and the shorter
back legs
about 2500 miles away a series of marine
heatwaves swept through the gulf of
california warming the surface
temperature of the water and impacting
various species including the humboldt
squid
humboldt squid are also known as jumbo
squid because they grow so large they
can be three four five even six feet in
length fishers in the gulf of california
were the first people to notice that
something had changed when they stopped
catching the humboldt squid when the
scientists arrived to study this
situation they found that in fact the
humble squid were still there and in
some places more plentiful than before
what had changed was their lifestyle and
their body these were not immature or
juvenile squid they were humble squid at
full size reproducing and carrying out
their lives in half the time they used
to dr william gilly and his team
measured the squid they caught and found
a reduction of 50 percent or more in
their body size in response to the
stress of the higher water temperatures
this adaptation is known as plasticity
plasticity is widely distributed in
nature some species have a lot of it
like the humboldt squid some species
have very little plasticity is already
built into the genome of a species it's
already there one example of plasticity
occurs when we travel to high altitudes
our body adapts to the low density of
the air and less oxygen by making more
red blood cells to compensate when we
return to sea level our body feels more
energized so can the fact that the
humboldt squid thrived in higher numbers
in its new fun size be considered a win
for the species
climate change biologists are reluctant
to identify winners and losers in this
great struggle for survival but
certainly species that have a plastic
response the way the squid do have a
great advantage over species with
limited plasticity
from the warm waters of mexico we travel
to the frigid north to study another
example of plasticity behavioral
plasticity in the feeding patterns of
this arctic bird i think we're all
familiar with that iconic climate change
image of the polar bear stranded on a
shrinking iceberg but if you could look
beyond the bear to the edge of the ice
you might catch a glimpse of a tiny sea
bird called the little awk or dove key
dove keys feed along the edge of the ice
floes where there are a lot of plankton
and that has been their strategy for
thousands of years it worked just fine
until the ice floes begin to shrink and
retreat farther and farther from the
islands where the dove keys breed
and you can imagine as that ice gets
farther and farther away the dove keys
have longer and longer to travel to
reach a place where they can get food
for their offspring and they have long
been predicted to be an early casualty
of climate change french scientists
david grimley and his team placed
transmitters on the birds
and wondered how long they would need to
fly to their usual plankton meal which
was now far away at the edge of the
retreating ice so when they gathered
around to collect the first batch of
data from their transmitters they were
astounded because instead of flying an
hour the dove keys had been in the air
for less than four minutes david and his
team realized that the dove keys had
found a new food source right on their
very doorstep at the mouth of the fjord
where the milky blue melt water from
island glaciers was slamming into the
dark cold currents of the arctic ocean
and creating this place of plenty for
the dove keys to feed upon the stunned
plankton the dove keys continue to
thrive by being flexible enough as a
species to switch up their traditional
feeding patterns and adapt quickly to a
changing environment
the new dovekey behavior is not a
permanent solution to climate change the
glaciers on those islands will melt away
and disappear but it buys the dove keys
time to find other ways to adapt to a
warmer world
plants and animals all over the world
adapting their behaviors sometimes
changing their bodies sometimes even
evolving in response to climate change
not all species will have the ability to
adapt quickly enough to climate change
the mouse-like bramble key melonies in
australia recently became the first
mammal species confirmed as a climate
change casualty when all of its known
habitat was flooded by sea level rise so
studying climate change biology does not
make scientists worry less about the
crisis but it can help them to worry
smart learning which species are more
resilient and which are most at risk so
that we can allocate scarce resources in
terms of research and conservation and
policy to the species that need our help
the most we can take inspiration from
plants and animals in terms of our own
response to the crisis after all if a
tiny lizard can evolve in response to
climate change then it stands to reason
we can change some of the behaviors that
are bringing it about